all right uh yeah you're right the 2007
super bowl championship all right uh
that is the best moment of eli manning's
career i mean let alone it was an epic
play-off run and they had played okay
the new england patriots in week 17 and
played them closely and gave them a
little bit of an issue
but ultimately that super bowl 42 is
what took eli manning into another
stratosphere as a quarterback as a
player under until 2007 and that year i
mean hey there was questions in the 2007
season of whether we should bench eli
should eli get benched and things like
that but he played amazing football and
the biggest moment of his career at that
point and beat the undefeated new
england patriots who looked unstoppable
really all year long and made one of the
great plays in super bowl history with
the david tyree and then of course the
plaxico burress touchdown to win the
football game
yeah absolutely i mean that's one of the
all-time great moments in nfl history
it's the obvious number one and hell why
wasn't i thinking of ja davey and
clowney all right uh for me it's the
mario manningham throw in super bowl 46.
it it was every bit as impactful it was
every bit as meaningful it fueled the
drive that ultimately won the game for
the giants and he was threading a needle
it was a great catch by mario manningham
but for eli manning to be able to put it
there yeah how far it traveled through
the air how it just kind of came right
in look at that he's got a guy in his
face and just drops it in between two
guys that was a thing of beauty and that
helped the giants get super bowl win
number two it helped eli get mvp number
two and i think that from a substantive
football standpoint is the thing that
gets him into canton yeah i i agree i
mean that that throw there alone
probably gets a minute all together
because if that's not completed uh most
likely the patriots win that football
game and that's that so i hear you that
was another another clutch performance
by eli i think you know the consecutive
starts thing or something i got to talk
about when the best moments of eli
manning's career i mean you know you
always hear the old phrase like the best
ability is availability right well eli
manning was always available now was it
as create courageous of a start you know
consecutive starting streak as like as
brett favre who played the game much
more physically than eli manning uh no
but still nonetheless what was it 207
starts in a row something like that i
mean that's just that's astounding to be
able to do that to be able to stay
upright healthy week after week i mean
that talks about the the talent the
toughness of the player as well and you
know the feel the feel of the player to
know oh these guys are around me or i'm
gonna get hit like this and the ability
to protect all of those things uh are
speak to the player eli manning was and
uh i think that's one of the more
impressive things he did in his career
was was play that many games in a row
that's the thing we take for granted
that's the thing that i think is a
critical aspect of our franchise
quarterback that's part of the value the
great value of dak press got four years
never missed a game you know as the
patriots decide what they're going to do
next whoever they get next a guy that
they believe will be durable because
remember when tom brady was suspended in
2016 jimmy garoppolo got hurt jacoby
brissett was banged up tom brady has
found a way to stay healthy all these
years except for the fluke acl tear week
one of 2008 that is a key component and
for eli manning you just take it for
granted the guy's there every week he
shows up every week it's okay but you
don't realize it until he's not there
when he is there no big deal well it is
a big deal because the alternative
for a lot of teams is going to be a big
drop off all right for me this goes all
the way back to draft day he did
something that only two high prior
profile quarterbacks have ever done
which is telling the team that held the
first overall pick in the draft don't
bother john elway did it to the colts
ending up with the broncos instead and
eli manning did it to the chargers he
didn't want to go to the charters now
look one of the reasons they want to go
to the chargers and this story is kind
of trickled out over time when he
visited the chargers he got mixed
signals about whether or not they really
wanted him that was when they had marty
schottenheimer and aj smith coach and gm
respectively they didn't see eye to eye
and he wasn't sure that they really
wanted they had drew brees at the time
so that's part of the reason why he
didn't want the chargers archie ran
interference for eli so he wouldn't look
like he was being you know a brat or or
you know being a guy who would push
against the system although i encourage
guys to push against the system i don't
like the fact that the draft dictates
where the best players go i like it when
they have power and they use it and eli
did and there he was if you're watching
on tv as a charger for a brief moment in
time before he was traded to the new
york giants so i love the fact and it
was such an eventful day when eli
manning made it clear to the chargers
i'm not coming they drafted him the
giants drafted philip rivers the deal
was done and now both guys moving on
from those teams in the same off-season
yeah that was a that was hey that was a
career defining moment before your
career even started yeah they you know
the manning family they're smart they're
intelligent they read the tea leaves the
right way there and they didn't like the
situation in the san diego at that time
probably realized there was too many
moving parts probably scared like what
if drew brees has a great year this next
year does eli become the starter when
does he become the starter so
that was that was a power play move by a
powerful nfl family and it all worked
out in the end for eli manning and the
mannings in general all right i mean hey
listen i could talk about
more games of the eli manning but i i
really think this this goes a long way
to me when you talk about the best
moments eli manning's career i'm gonna
talk about his acting in commercials i
mean to me that's where like
he became humanized and where i really
like went another level in liking eli
manning i mean there's just so many
things whether it's the dirty dancing
with odell beckham jr i mean come on
that's hilarious he had like the fantasy
football rap video right with his
brother that was as funny as it gets
some of those espn commercials where
they're kicking each other in the butt
and giving each other wet willies in the
ears and all those kind of things i mean
he's a very funny funny guy and as you
see right here the fact that he's on his
knees doing dirty dancing and doing a
whole dance like patrick swayze is
hilarious and i really that made me
respect eli to another level
yeah and yeah i mean he because
he he's so much more reserved than
peyton but he's got the same chops when
it comes to
acting and comedy and you know we really
don't know what eli's going to do next
but just like with peyton i feel like
whatever he chooses to do he'll be
successful even though he's more
reserved even though outwardly he's more
muted i think he's still got a lot of
the same qualities and talents and
characteristics of peyton and i think
he'll be around uh at least as much as
peyton has been around then again peyton
in four years hasn't been around nearly
as much as we thought he would be
although he's still a heavy presence in
commercials all right for me i thought
you were going to take my last one
because for me it's also a non-playing
characteristic of eli manning he split
the
water payton man of the year award with
larry fitzgerald after the 2016 season
he has been a great voice and a great
fundraiser when it comes to children
with cancer one of the best causes that
anyone could have he's been a champion
in that regard when we're in the new
york area during weekends in football
season and can see some of the local
channels and some of the local coverage
some of the local commercials how
passionate he is about it i mean it's
heartbreaking for anyone of any age to
have to deal with a disease like that
but especially a child to have to go
through treatments like that and endure
that uncertainty and fear and
he's been a true true pioneer among nfl
players when it comes to that cause and
and that to me
definitely stands out uh because i think
it's something he hasn't gotten enough
credit for and i have a feeling it's
something he's going to stay heavily
involved in even in his retirement yeah
i i would think so too i mean he's
really made a name for himself up here
in the tri-state area with
all the work he's done with kids and
cancer and everything like that it's a
great cause you know eli's uh he's great
that way he really is he's one of those
guys you meet him you talk to him for a
minute and you realize he's a good
person and he just has good person in
his eyes in general when you look into
them and uh a legend for me man i mean
awesome i mean eli manning applause all
i can do over here is it's chant eli
like the giant fans always used to i
mean he was he was special and fun to
watch gave me a lot of great memories
you know the giants are the team that's
truest to my heart and uh
you know hey i love my dad and his
career eli manning's career very special
and he's the the king quarterback in the
history of the new york giants franchise
and we do have that eli manning
connection from before we ever even met
where i made a smart aleck remark about
eli manning in the 80s throwback
uniforms and i made some
derogatory reference to phil yes in
reference to the way eli played that
night and you saw that and you were
upset with me about it i was yeah what a
jerk you are yeah what a jerk taking low
blows on big phil right below the right
hitting him below the belt that's what
mike for copy paste copy paste snarky
comment that's how i got a little it's
the only place i can hit him
he's a giant
yup but you're right that'll be that
that one did it got me pissed off that
one day it was like a power rankings
back in like 2016 or i found it the last
time you brought it up i found it
it wasn't that bad
we've had more thin skin than derek carr
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports